Reggie Jackson wanted to be an owner of
a baseball team and here's one of the
greatest baseball players of all time so
he put together a what they call a
Consortium of people to buy a team one
of those was um Bill Gates was part of
your team you had Bill Gates you could
pay whatever you were willing to pay 25
what million more than anyone else in
writing I sent a letter to Ken Hoffman
who only A's
um that I'm willing to pay 25 million
more than any bid that you get a bud
said to me said Reggie stay with me I'll
uh guide you through I'll get this done
for you uh don't worry about it and then
all of a sudden it came out that the A's
were sold to a guy by the name of Lou
wolf
Bud Seeley's College buddy
you must have been destroyed it broke my
heart I was I went into depression for
about six months you think the owners
got together trying to have a discussion
and say yeah we don't know Reggie's a
troublemaker what do we need him I
absolutely believe that
um and I absolutely believe that bud was
the guy involved
that denied me from getting the team
I had a
100 a 100 page lawsuit drawn up
uh I still have the deck it's about
three four inches thick
and there's six inches of
text message and text messages and all
that kind of stuff that went back and
forth I never filed it why not I got
scared Away by some people in baseball I
said Reggie the first thing you have to
do is resign from baseball
from the Yankees you know and you
probably won't get hired again you
probably won't this and probably won't
that and so I got scared away because it
would have killed you not to be a part
of baseball you love it and I didn't
know enough about the legal system you
know Etc but I should have sued I didn't
um and and it's obviously still in my
craw
I get a chance to talk about it now I do
have backup
you know for it you know there that I've
got a letter that is in writing dated
December of 2002 or three I put a group
together with Bill Gates Paul Allen and
a guy named John McCall
um I could have bought the national
league it did right that's my point I
mean when it comes down to whether or
not you got the money you had the money
it has to be something else you're not
part of the good old boys club that's
right